[Musica]
guardo che monterey california
circondata da pesci coloratissimi si
svolge la prima conferenza the del mondo
due fondatori sono convinti che
l'intersezione frati technology
essenzialmente di design in questo
spazio di intersezione c'è l'impulso per
l'innovazione
fin dalla prima edizione eccezionale
pensate che nel 1984 si presentò la demo
del compact disc e la demo del ebook
la conferenza diventa leggendaria cresce
negli anni diventa un mito salto avanti
25 anni 2009 la mitica conferenza the in
un gesto di apertura radicale decide di
regalare la sua barca a cittadini e
cittadine che in ogni parte del mondo
siano disposti a lavorare come volontari
per fare una conferenza allestì l'hotel
nella loro città nel loro paese nel loro
piccolissimo villaggio nella loro scuola
elementare nella loro università
chiama la licenza at ed ex dove l'aex
vuol dire appunto un evento locale
organizzato in modo dipendente sullo
stile tempo ci sono alcune regole
naturalmente la la licenza gratuita ma
ci sono tre o quattro principi da
rispettare che sono gli stessi sono
sempre stati gli stessi duranti dieci
anni tutti gli organizzatori sono
volontari
l'evento non può fare nessun profitto se
c'è un surplus di un euro bisogna
donarlo a un'energia oppure a investirlo
nell'evento seguente e lei devo dovrà
essere veramente dipendenti indipendenti
da spirit e corporativi religiosi o
politici inoltre tutte le idee generate
sullo stage devono essere tradotte in un
video che poi si mette a disposizione
gratuitamente per il mondo che pensava
che qualche decina di città avrebbe
colto queste offerte avrebbe forse
organizzato un evento in questo stile
totalmente no profit invece la linea
senza ottiene uno sviluppo
inimmaginabile e in questi decenni sono
stati realizzati 31020 tedes 31.000 in
ogni angolo del mondo nei sei continenti
non solo non solo perché per esempio
oggi un solo un sabato ci sono 37 20 in
ogni angolo del pianeta cina brasile
messico danimarca inghilterra oggi solo
oggi anche una firenze
inoltre la creatività degli
organizzatori che pazzesca è stata
capace di espandere la licenza e fare
delle cose incredibili è stato fatto un
telex in un treno nel treno tra
amsterdam e mastri un terrazzo 2
dell'amazzonia 1 sui ghiacci
dell'antartide 1 sull'everest uno sulle
dolomiti nelle favelas nelle piazze
pubbliche sotto un ponte che divideva i
ricchi dai poveri
addirittura è stato fatto un telex
doppio che si sviluppava da un lato e
l'altro del muro che divide negli stati
uniti dal messico per dimostrare che le
idee non possono essere circondate da
muri perché comunque vanno e volano
ovunque si è così
una città una città che accoglie un
evento tedeschi una città che appoggia
un evento tedesco una città che
abbraccia un evento the debt riceve
molte cose a cambio e oggi ne avete
avuto un'esperienza molto precisa
prima di tutto crea dei cittadini molto
meglio informati molto più sofisticati
molto più autonomi è molto più
indipendenti molto più attivi non solo
culturalmente ma anche socialmente e
anche economicamente e poi c'è un altro
grande premio vede e l'esperienza di
oggi 400 persone che un sauna pomeriggio
invece di andare a divertirsi o al
cinema hanno deciso di venire qua e
tutti insieme questi 400 stanno
ascoltando delle idee e se ci pensate
non sono molte le circostanze nelle
quali andiamo fisicamente in un luogo
per fare una cosa tutti insieme perché
l'attenzione è una cosa molto seria
prestare attenzione oggi è una cosa
difficile l'attenzione è il valore
fondamentale di questi giorni in cui
siamo tutti immersi nei nostri
telefonini o nel netflix ma c'è di più
c'è di più perché vedete le dodici o
tredici idee che oggi avete ascoltato
non finiscono mica qui in questa stanza
pura peraltro meravigliosa no no no
vanno trasformate in video firmate
foggia the debt foggia per questo c'è
logo paddy dietro questo luogo è
importantissimo queste dodici o tredici
de volano e vanno a confluire
nell'archivio di idee orali più grande
del mondo
in cinquanta lingue 147 mila video di
idee ed ex prodotte in questi dieci anni
viste 4.000 milioni di volte oggi sono
147 mila più 12 e quindi le idee di
questi 12 13 speaker cominceranno a
dialogare con tutto quanto già si è
detto su queste questioni
lì al gabinetto per esempio comincerà a
dialogare se volete perché queste magari
la vostra linea di studio sui problemi
di gabinetto
sapete che ci sono 100 milioni di
persone al mondo che non hanno un
gabinetto sapete quanta gente sta
investendo per fare dell'innovazione
sul water su cosa possiamo fare per
portare il vate e ovunque
cosa possiamo fare per riciclare i
prodotti del mater e potito scoprirebbe
per esempio in questo grande serbatoio
di 147mila che lui non è per niente solo
perché ci sono tanti altri ragazzi come
lui che viaggiano soli in questo viaggio
del flight di fiducia e scopriremo anche
che queste idee di alexa l'algoritmo
eccetera sono molto più preoccupanti di
quanto siano state presentate oggi se
oggi se siamo disposti ad ascoltare
alcuni di questi speaker che vedete
alcune delle idee
entrano in dialogo e sono toccano
terreni prossimi ma ci sono idee che
sono l'opposto di quelle che abbiamo
ascoltato oggi è ugualmente ben
argomentate e questo è meraviglioso
perché è un dispositivo contro pensiero
unico contro l'arroganza di pensare che
abbiamo sempre ragione
ed è anche diciamo una base per per
imparare di più per sapere di più e per
creare il nostro proprio punto di vista
io sono un organico un organizer sono
anche una bassano ho fatto il tedesco
madrid 40 volte è stata una delle prime
licenze del mondo abbiamo fatto 40
edizioni adesso se ne stanno facendo
ancora tantissime e sono anche dal
bassano quindi entro il contatto
costantemente con tedeschi tutto il
mondo conosco centinaia di organizzatori
devo dire che la mia figura è veramente
molto molto fortunato e mi chiedono
sempre tutti ma perchè perchè fate una
cosa dove prima di tutto non potete
guadagnare denaro perché proibito né voi
stessi nel nostro evento spendete un
sacco di tempo otto mesi dieci mesi
preoccupazioni anche notti in bianco
devo dire ma perché lo fate
e una risposta razionale veramente non
c'è però secondo me per concludere
questo evento tedeschi era fuori il
meglio di noi che è quando facciamo le
cose senza uno scopo commerciale ne
facciamo perché le vogliamo fare perché
non possiamo non farle perchè perchè le
facciamo per amore punto e secondo me se
lo chiedete a loro vi daranno la stessa
risposta a questi creatori della stanza
delle meraviglie che in realtà sono loro
le meraviglie e adesso col vostro
permesso li chiamo tutti sul palco per
un applauso finale
cominciando dal gruppo che ha fatto la
logistica dell'evento nei suoi infiniti
perché questo evento come avete
immaginato è molto complicato mara
distaso dove sei
mara ma ora maradona dopo andrea
giardino andrea giardino angelo lorizzo
annamaria scaltrito da mila da ciano
donato de michele dove sei donato donato
de michele francesca silva gian luca
mechini dove sei gianluca via via
giovanni box giovanni ci sei
ilaria giuliano kevin che lincoln i pali
che è stato qui dietro a mettere le
persone sotto ai pannelli giusti lucia
olea dove sei lucia marco lepore marco
manzo ma dove sei maria pia senatore
vittoria garcia al mare pasquale
iannella raffaele lucà rocchino dove sei
rocchino del priore sarà caputo dove sei
sarà silvia valenti fondamentali
stefania bonassisa stefano simone
tommaso esposto ci sei ti esponi tommaso
luca e odiosi mario gaudiosi siete
fratelli si domenico d'alessandro maria
palmieri e fotografi
sergio pupino ricerca degli sponsor
ragazzi fate i rilievi
se volete sponsor i a questo evento
fantastico desire mantovano donato
cerone dove siete ragazzi social media
manager fabio consiglio che non c'è però
ho fatto la scenografia è veri fans
concetta lapomarda blogger
daniela simoncelli aspetti legali
simonetti gli aspetti legali e gestore
dei volontari federica mirabella michele
maffione il 3 mondiale logistica e
gestione dei venti ragazzi andiamo
buster volte walter va al tar
vabbè seccatore elena e le mani libro
ufficio stampa elena dove sei
a white mario zagaria esperto in
sicurezza informatica
[Applauso]
va beh ecco la guardava su laura
marinaccio graphic designer nichi
dell'anno produttore esecutivo d'aria
che faccia 7 slimer in usa per il
cineporto verdetti gianni video audio
digitale george michael ha draisci
logistica
[Applauso]
gianfranco del vicario il lettore
creativo vayan così estrazione per me è
giuseppe prisco
[Applauso]